I suspect a foul play and that  eliminated no suspects I am detective  lieutenant Elliot and this is trooper  Wagner we just want to ask a few  questions  we understand none of his demise the  family have gathered to celebrate your  father's 85th birthday  how was it hello the party pre my dad's  death that was great ladies and  gentlemen I would like to request that  you all stay until the investigation is  completed what can we ask why has  something changed no no it hasn't  changed or no we can't ask one of his  family walls is that what you're  suggesting  [Music]  you all love twisting the knife into one  another up your ass oh very perfect oui  chef how's that  eat [ __ ] [ __ ] definitely eat  you know something spill it  I suspect foul play  I have eliminated no suspects  [Music]  to twist it web we are not finished  untangling it not yet  what is this CSI KFC  you